hi how are you
[Music]
i was um you're gonna think i'm poking
fun at you when i'm not i don't think
you're a funny stand-up
but the relapse thing the way you said
it
that's fun that's a joke
and that's the kind of stuff you should
do
like jokes that's inspired by reality
that's right just showing your dick and
pretending to be angry
oh is that what you're thinking my stand
up as well yeah i'm angry on stage yeah
oh
interesting
so you know i've invited you to do shows
with me
yeah yeah and i wanted to do more but i
guess
you don't want to anymore bobby yeah
you've invited me to do two shows in
five years yeah yeah and both of those
shows you talk about how great i am and
you're gonna have me back right away and
months and months the years go by yeah
yeah until you finally have me back and
all you do is say you didn't want me
here
you know it's a joke all right and
that's what i'm confident about and
that's what you're doing no i love you
know i think you're funny i love it i
think i love what you're doing i think
you're so good and and uh you know what
i want to be honest and truthful with
you all right and let's start there
honest and truth all right give us a
five go ahead
we're gonna start now five four three
two welcome to another episode of the
truth podcast
and being honestly open
that's what our podcast about tiger
belly we have the most greatest guy
tiger tiger i mean kirk glassman
[Laughter]
sorry sorry babe right
we're not gonna i'm gonna keep we'll fix
that and compost yeah all right send it
to me we'll send it to you
right we have a beautiful um man okay
straight from
the valley
oh
do you live there right yeah yeah yeah
and he is honest and open good guy very
glass but anyway i want to say this this
morning when i woke up i go are we doing
the podcast today and chloe goes rick
lassman and i got instantly erect
and it wasn't a sexual erection it was
like my life energy going into the
[ __ ] organ
what's the difference between a sexual
erection and your life energy going into
your life force is different yeah
because it depends on what you're
thinking about you know how sometimes
you wake up with the morning wood yeah
that's life force that's life force
isn't that uh insulin
that's life i don't know i'm not
diabetic so i don't know
but anyway um i had anything wrong with
by the way and we love diet it's
diabetics it's yeah we love diets love
diabetes we love diet we like both we
like them and i want to say this okay
what a pleasure thank you so much for
coming
and you know what also we had a little
time thing i was getting my hair cut i
go is there any way rick can come later
and you obliged
really appreciate that oblige doesn't
that kind of sound like a golden girl
that didn't make it
a really funny joke and you're going to
play with words
puns
very witty
let me ask you something how many
vitamins are there
essential or non-essential i'm just
saying i'm thinking like there's vitamin
a right b right is there an eye yes
what's it
uh lactose intolerancy it's a lactate
okay is there a vitamin m
yeah what steak because every time i
take a bite i go
[Music]
no i have been trying to not eat meat
i've been doing i had okay